the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
i've been waiting a long time to put
this amount of money
into education tonight on politics now
more money for k-12 schools the first
steps being taken to change how we pay
for education
near the end of the road the work
lawmakers still have to do as the
legislative session winds down
i think anybody who's been to an outdoor
concert knows that
there are folks consuming there pot
lounges and pot vendors a nevada
dispensary association explores laws
that could impact how the state's
marijuana industry moves forward
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler lifting
restrictions in a little more than a
week clark county is going back to its
pre-pandemic rules
commissioners voted to fully reopen the
county on june 1st
so that will include lifting
restrictions on capacity limits
large gatherings and dancing initially
clark county said the vaccination rate
needed
needed to reach 60 percent before
removing these guidelines
but this week the commissioners changed
their mind so this means event companies
can
get back to booking parties and
conventions county commission chair
marilyn kirkpatrick says the new centers
for disease control guidance
spurred this move we've been doing
really well in our community as a whole
as you just heard from dr lagann
so we went back and we evaluated it and
as you know the cdc came out and made
some guidance last thursday which just
had us evaluate it sooner rather than
later
it's worth pointing out though
commissioners say if hospitals get
overloaded again
the restrictions could return we are
quickly approaching the end of the
eviction moratorium here in nevada it
ends june 1st
the cdc's version lasts until the end of
june
so if you're struggling to stay in your
home because of the pandemic
clark county has these recommendations
if you get a notice for eviction
file a response with the appropriate
justice court requesting mediation
triggers a review by the county
a caseworker will reach out and guide
you through the county's rental
assistance application that's called
chap
assistant county manager kevin schiller
says several agencies and departments at
clark county and the state are all
coming together for this
and with that moratorium ending and as
we move forward
this collaboration has not existed in
the history of the state
so what this will allow for is a
connection point between mediators
the chap rental assistance program and
clark county
in conjunction with the courts about
9 000 people are currently waiting for
their chap application to be processed
clark county says it's bringing on more
workers to handle those cases
a household of four making up to 60
thousand dollars a year is eligible for
this assistance
the program itself has a hundred sixty
million dollars still
and that can help forty thousand
households in clark county
a bill introduced in the state assembly
on thursday would require
courts to pause evictions for
non-payment if the renter
has a rental assistance application
pending with chap
if the landlord refuses the assistance
the renter would be able to sue for
wrongful eviction
state lawmakers are facing a june first
deadline to finish the
legislative session with a lot of work
left to do the nevada legislature
putting its money
where its mouth is on school funding now
a joint budget committee is giving an
extra 500 million dollars in new money
for k-12 education in the next two years
schools will also be funded through a
new pupil centered program
plan it's been in the works for some
time now but until now no new money was
set aside for it
assembly speaker jason fryerson
addressed accusations the legislature
wasn't taking education seriously
here we are now looking at i think
historic support for public education
which
again it doesn't happen on the sidewalks
it also doesn't happen on social media
while all that's going on we're working
with our staff it's not every day that
you get to do something that i think
will be significantly
impactful for students but i do think
today is one of those days
money will go to the base amount given
to schools for each student about
ninety one hundred dollars for next year
now if you would like to learn about how
that new pupil centered funding plan
works we have an explainer video
available for you at eightnewsnow.com
senate bill 420 would create a public
option health care plan
and it now has another amendment to
lower some of the costs
the new part deals with a portion of the
bill that expands who's eligible for
medicaid
it says the state would only expand the
eligibility if there was money available
a previous amendment would also delay
the start of a public option until 2026.
right now that bill is sitting in the
senate finance committee and has not yet
had a floor vote
emergency gun legislation introduced by
senate majority leader nicole cannizzaro
had its first hearing this week
assembly bill 286 bans ghost guns
it was amended to take out added
criminal penalties for people who
violate a private businesses
no guns allowed on property signs
senator canazzaro introduced a new bill
this week
which introduces that legislation again
the nevada firearms coalition calls the
bill unnecessary
it claims existing trespass laws allow
people to ban firearms at their
businesses already
a few more bills have died after failing
to make legislative deadlines
some of the more prominent ones are
ab-395 which would have abolished the
death penalty
assembly bill 28268 which would have
required written use of force policies
for law enforcement
and ab339 which would have created
domestic violence treatment programs in
justice courts
north las vegas mayor john lee has a new
party and a new target
governor of nevada lee recently became a
republican
after serving for a long time as a
democrat well the official filing
deadline for running for governor isn't
until march
so the republican field is still shaping
up mayor lee says he's going to run for
governor
congressman mark amaday and clark county
sheriff joe lombardo both have said they
may run
on the democratic side governor steve
sisilak hasn't really drawn any big-name
challengers yet
businessman don ahern is the new finance
chairman for nevada's republican party
ahern owns his own rental company in
town and the ahern hotel and convention
center on sahara
this is some video from a trump rally at
the hotel last year
in fact ahern was fined for violating
capacity limits there during the
pandemic
he was also on former president trump's
finance team
ordering marijuana with ease
our customers really liked it and they
really liked the ease of ordering online
and being able to come and pick it up
will nevada finally give people a place
to smoke their pot
[Music]
the nevada legislature is still
requiring masks in carson city
right now fully vaccinated people can
take off the mask
within a legislative building but the
masks are still required in public
areas of the legislative complex
republican assemblywoman annie black of
mesquite was censored on
thursday for violating those rules in
response
black tweeted she was permanently barred
for refusing to wear a mask on the
assembly floor unless she apologizes
well assembly rules state shield won't
be allowed to vote or speak on the floor
or in committee except to explain and
apologize for the breach
first as we near the last week of the
legislative session one growing area of
nevada's economy
hasn't really been addressed so far
we're talking about marijuana
bills that deal with creating pot
lounges pot vendor licenses and curbside
pickup
haven't gotten a vote recreational
marijuana has been legal in nevada for
four years however
no new places to use it have been
created i spoke with the new
executive director of the nevada
dispensary association
it's been a while since pot has become
legal and and the discussion of lounges
dates back almost to that point how come
it's taken so long
to get this framework in place one way
or another
i think one of the key factors was
having the
cannabis compliance board set up so the
canada compliance board was
created during the 2019 legislative
session and
just started on july 1 of 2020.
so having that regulatory body modeled
after the gaming control board
um that is overseeing the industry i
think was a key factor in
you know whether this additional new
license type that will require
uh additional staff to enforce and it's
just you know it's very new
um i think having that regulatory body
in place maybe give some folks some
security and thinking like okay now
might be the time
to do this also the ccv conducted a
study
um that they submitted to the
the legislature at the beginning of the
session assessing
whether cannabis lounges you know
how that would work and so i think those
in combination
um really set the stage for what's
happening this session
there's also another measure that looks
at uh trying to allow marijuana
uh at large events sort of like beer
gardens and so forth
we i i summon bill 322 sort of
pot gardens i guess talk about this
measure if you can and
and why it might go a little forward
so 322 is um sometimes referred to as
like pop-up vendor event so what it
creates is a vendor license
so if you have an an outdoor concert or
something
um that is serving individuals who are
21 and over
um there would be an opportunity to
create an
area of that is um
designated specifically for consumption
and allow individuals
to um to to vent you know sort of like
an alcohol distributor at
an outdoor concert they would be able to
sell at the event
in a designated location and this
is um another bill that could create
opportunity to enter the industry
at a low cost senate bill 168 deals with
a
curbside pickup for marijuana which kind
of came out of the pandemic as well
um there's a lot of
measures that took place during the
pandemic that i'm curious whether
they're going to last
beyond the pandemic and i guess this is
kind of one of them talk about this
measure if you can
and again why marijuana dispensaries in
nevada
would uh are in favor of it yeah so
curbside pickup was created by the
governor's emergency order last spring
in order to ease uh to reduce capacity
in store
and to make sure that there weren't
lines in parking lots and
so it turns out customers really liked
it and they really like the ease of
ordering online and being able to come
and pick it up
and especially for medical patients or
elderly patients
who don't have it you know for it's more
difficult for them to get out of the car
um so they really liked it and so
dispensaries asked
the nda uh to bring this bill and we
worked closely with the cannabis
compliance board
to to draft this bill to make curbside
pick up a permanent feature
and so far the bill has gained
bipartisan support
um and it's it's on track to you know
fingers crossed it's on track to pass
what's the future the future is you know
continuing to um
continuing to work with the ccb you know
as the ccb
gets set up and working with them on
making
changes to better the industry for
instance one of the things that we're
planning on working on this summer with
the ccb
is a more comprehensive review and
reform of packaging and labeling
regulations and it doesn't sound super
interesting but it really is because we
are we have regulations for
labeling that date back several years
several years in this industry is like
five
but packaging has really changed since
then and
our knowledge of the best ways to convey
consumer warnings
um the information that really should be
included on a label
has evolved and now versus when
we first started to now other
jurisdictions have come online there's
all sorts of public health expertise
that we can bring in including end users
and say like okay what
what's helpful to have on a cannabis
label and can we make the cannabis you
know
should it look like a food label and you
know if you're comparing two products
that you can easily make a determination
between the two where right now
our compliances are our regulations are
sort of outdated and some of them were
duplicative in terms of what needs to be
on labels
so like i said stuff like that it helps
advance the industry and
go back and and update and modernize
some of those regulations
that were put in place at the very
beginning i also think we have an
opportunity to make the industry more
environmentally conscious look at some
regulations that have to do with
packaging or that have to do with other
areas
and say okay like we have gotten to a
place where we
have addressed a lot of the safety
issues related to packaging and products
and now how can we evolve into into the
next
the next sort of iteration how do we go
back through and make sure that we're
being environmentally conscious as well
now just after we did that interview
there was an amendment to the
consumption lounge bill that we
discussed independent lounges were taken
out
so it will not include allowing people
to bring a product into a licensed
place to consume it there she had
mentioned yoga studios as an example
and we're going to stay on top of these
bills we will let you know if any of
them pass before the end of the
legislative session
next on politics now reviving tourism
the first meeting for a key subcommittee
chaired by nevada senator jackie rosen
plus a potential cease-fire in the
israeli-palestinian conflict
nevada's democratic chairwoman speaks
out and gets condemned
after a week and a half there is now a
tenuous cease fire in israel as we tape
this program on friday
reports indicate israel's war cabinet
has approved a unilateral ceasefire
after increasing pressure from the bidet
administration
and other countries around the world
however israel has threatened to respond
with
a new level of force if hamas keeps
firing rockets at them
the white house was defensive when asked
if president joe biden had done enough
to try and stop the fighting
do you not count the 80 engagements
we've had with countries around the
world including the president's call
with
the leader of egypt the four calls he's
had with
the israeli prime minister i think it is
shameful that the radical left in the
democratic party
is choosing this moment to try to
undermine our friend and ally
joining us to talk about the white
house's response to the conflict in the
middle east alex limon from our
washington bureau
alexander let's talk about the
administration the bide administration's
response to the conflict and where
things stand
it's been interesting to watch this
develop you know throughout the week
because we initially heard from the
white house that
president biden had spoken to prime
minister netanyahu
and had said that he supported a
de-escalation in the conflict between
israel and gaza
and the white house was trying to be as
diplomatic as possible at that point but
as we all saw it really didn't change
anything
and in fact we saw the bomb bombardments
just continue and hundreds of people
die as a result and so then later in the
week we
heard the white house say that the
president had talked to netanyahu once
again
and that had in this case asked more
forcefully for
a de-escalation on that day and again we
saw that
israel's response was that that just
didn't happen
and the fighting continued and so it
kind of put the the white house in an
uncomfortable position both
diplomatically with israel
but also back here at home where we saw
a lot of
lawmakers democrats in congress you know
telling the administration that they
wanted the president to be much
more forceful to try to get the conflict
and
the deaths to stop and on that note
some democrats are proposing stopping in
arms sale by the u.s to
israel it was about to go through let's
talk about what the weapons proposal the
sale
is and why some democrats wanted to stop
right and the issue is that these
democrats were kind of working against
the clock here because they really had a
really limited amount of time something
like five days or so
to try to stop that arm sale it was
about 730 million dollars worth of jdam
so it's equipment that essentially makes
missiles more precise
and also from what we understand small
diameter bombs
and so a lot of democrats really
progressive democrats in the house were
saying we should not be
selling you know any type of arms to
israel at a time when there is such a
conflict happening
and that was alexander limon reporting
from washington d.c
the new chair of nevada's democratic
party did issue a statement about the
israeli conflict and it immediately
brought criticism
judith whitmer accused the united states
government of having quote
too long turned a blind eye to injustice
and violence committed by the israeli
government
dominated by the extreme right wing
unquote well that caused the newly
elected
treasurer of the democratic state party
to quit saying the state party needed to
be focused on electing democrats
and not sending out foreign policy
statements democrats from the
nevada's delegation responded all saying
they support israel's right to defend
itself so here's what congresswoman dina
titus told the items vanessa murphy
both sides have a right to live in peace
but
israel also has a right to defend itself
we're hoping for an end to the violence
because
uh civilians are being killed
i i didn't directly respond to the
statement by the party
okay but i can't say generally speaking
the party doesn't make policy it's there
to help incumbents help
candidates raise money do field work
that sort of thing
fellow democratic congresswoman susie
lee expressed a similar sentiment here
is her statement saying quote
i wholeheartedly condemn any statements
that ignore the history and complicated
nature of the israeli-palestinian
conflict
and the fact that israel is under attack
of course that was before the
cease-fire took effect nevada senator
jackie rosen
is the chair of the key subcommittee on
tourism in washington d.c
this week she held a hearing focused on
international tourism and travel
in order to try and bring back american
jobs the democrat pointed out how hard
las vegas economy has been impacted by
the pandemic
she highlighted other states around the
country that also depend on tourism and
that they're also hurting
senator rosen is urging for change as
the world emerges from the pandemic
it's such a daunting challenge to
overcome in order to
fully recover from the pandemic and turn
the corner toward economic growth
we must invest and promote tourism
at a greater level than ever before
senator rosen says panels like these are
the first steps to fully healing our
national
and local economy specifically of course
with tourism
speakers for former attorney general
adam laxaltz
conservative basque fry are taking shape
the republican holds his annual
fundraiser on august 14th up in corley
nevada
laxalt says speakers this year at the
gop event will include
arkansas senator tom cotton florida
governor ron desantis
and former u.s ambassador richard
grinnell the event raises money for
laxalt's morning in nevada political
action committee
[Music]
in what to watch well we've been talking
about it throughout the entire program
but the last week of the legislative
session in carson city is here
so far only a few dozen bills have
passed
and we're keeping an eye on education
funding health care
pot lounges and if any of the use of
force or police reform bills will
actually make it through
we're also keeping an eye on whether
governor sysolak ends up using his veto
pen
during this legislative session also
turning back the hands of time
clark county goes back to its
pre-pandemic rules june 1st
so we'll keep an eye on how that goes
and if nevada can slowly
continue to get people vaccinated it's a
long process to be sure we'll keep an
eye on that for you
we thank you very much for watching us
here on politics now you can stay up to
date on all the political news online at
eightnewsnow.com
and you can watch us here every saturday
on channel 8. we thank you for joining
us and we'll see you again next week
[Music]
you